aujourd'hui je vous présente des
écouteurs des écouteurs colorés qui ont
de la couleur de la lumière d'un côté et
de l'autre et en plus cette lumière va
venir changer en fonction de la musique
que vous écoutez elle va être soit fixe
soit moduler pouvez venir la changer
totalement là j'ai un petit mélange de
rouge et bleu je peux le mettre sur un
espèce de de bleu comme ça ou sur
l'oranger ou sur un rouge un petit
violet une espèce de mélange de couleur
du vert bref je fais ce que je veux je
trouve ça génial je vais tout vous
expliquer
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec jipod alors
plutôt la boîte qui fabrique les jeepot
qui s'appelle Edge o Jane puis son Hong
Kong et qui m'ont dit tiens bon monsieur
greu ouais on m'appelle soit mon bon
monsieur greu est-ce que tu voudrais pas
venir tester montrer les jeeps je trouve
ça marrant pourquoi parce que on connaît
plein d'écouteurs il y en a des tonnes
de toutes les formes toutes les tailles
alors peut-être que vous connaissez vous
mais moi j'en avais jamais vu qui
faisait de la lumière et je dois
reconnaître que ça me fait assez marrer
alors pour bien vous les montrer il faut
quand même pas mal baisser la lumière
comme carrément la couper donc là vous
voyez je suis sur un ma couleur verte
alors j'ai la lumière en plus bleu à
côté là qui forcément fait ressortir
tout ça mais voyez il y a vachement de
couleur et je trouve ça super rigolo
donc je vous montre je vous explique
comment ça se passe en fait les gypodes
elles arrivent dans cette petite boîte
là
dans cette boîte là vous avez une notice
qui vous explique comment ça marche avec
un guide d'utilisateur qui est bien fait
l'application venir télécharger bref le
truc est cool bien fait ça marche c'est
sympa ok ça me va vous avez en plus
différentes tailles d'embout parce qu'on
a pas tous les mêmes oreilles le small
le médium le large par défaut ça doit
être le XS qui est posé dessus et
personnellement ça me va bien ça rend
très facilement dans le regard c'est un
truc qui coule c'est qu'en fait la tenue
dans l'oreille est très bonne voyez je
prends hop je tourne légèrement sur des
bugs et là je suis connecté donc ça
c'est vachement bien ensuite dans la
boîte et bien on a pas grand chose alors
il y a un autre truc qui m'ont le donner
à moi c'est le coffret pour les
influenceurs j'aime pas trop le mot
influenceur en tout cas c'est le coffret
qu'ils ont et dans ce coffret vous avez
un truc qui est très cool c'est qu'ils
ont des petits accessoires détachables
que vous pouvez venir mettre dessus pour
personnaliser alors je vous montre
regardez on va prendre ça par exemple
vous voyez ça en fait c'est un
accessoire détacha vous pouvez venir
mettre dessus qui va venir apporter un
petit dessin supplémentaire donc je
prends jour il y a un côté un peu
faux-ongles alors je déteste les
faux-ongles je vous le dis directement
alors c'est pas des faux-ongles en fait
ça vient se poser directement sur vos
écouteurs regardez vous le prenez et
vous le positionne dessus ça vient c'est
très facilement d'un côté et de l'autre
on va faire pareil pour le deuxième je
prends mon écouteur je mets ça dessus et
ça me permet d'avoir un truc qui est
assez marrant alors là je vous le montre
il y a un côté un peu vert dessus je
peux le mettre avec un fond un peu
violet ça c'est marrant aussi en violet
comme ça parce que là tout vert ça pète
quand même pas mal ce qui fait que vous
les prenez vous le positionner dans
votre oreille comme ça et vous avez
votre petite décoration directement dans
l'oreille attendez je vais mettre là je
le verrai mieux parce que j'ai le
moniteur qui est de ce côté là vous
voyez donc là je l'ai à l'oreille et
c'est assez marrant ça c'est la base ok
bon les petites décorations je trouve ça
marrant vous les enlever facilement
gardez vous posez votre ongle là et vous
le déclipsez vous le retirez après vous
le remettez dans cette espèce de de
tuyau de flûte d'Ocarina de je sais pas
quoi vous venez les glisser à
l'intérieur la petite pastille collante
et vous le refermez alors il existe
plein mais ça on le verra juste après
que je vous montre déjà le principe
alors ce sont des petits bugs les
écouteurs je vous ai expliqué ça marche
bien sont connectés grâce à une
application alors compatible évidemment
iOS Android iOS à partir de la version
13 et Android à partir de la version 6
dans l'application vous pouvez venir
choisir de changer la couleur de vos
écouteurs vous avez plein de couleurs
par exemple Halloween vous voyez ça met
la couleur Halloween à côté
galaxie vous voyez rendu à chaque fois
et c'est exactement le même donc ça
c'est marrant embrasser la chaleur c'est
marrant le rose claque pas mal ce rose
trou noir avec un petit dégradé de
couleur donc vous voyez vous avez des
raccourcis là vous appuyez dessus vous
les avez alors ça c'est le premier
niveau donc ça c'est très très cool déjà
vous choisissez la couleur en plus peut
venir vous complètement la personnaliser
la customiser vous avez une petite
palette en regardant elle est juste là
vous cliquez dessus et là vous avez le
choix palette de couleur capture de
couleur photo couleur regardez j'ai
acheté ça l'autre fois quand j'étais aux
États-Unis c'est un stickers pour ma
valise ben je peux venir capturer en
fait la couleur de mon sticker capture
de couleur je fais une photo utilisée je
vais mettre le blanc rouge prévision ça
vient scanner et ça me propose ça en
fait et là je peux l'appliquer donc là
j'ai la couleur de ma photo donc ce qui
est très cool avec ça c'est que si vous
voulez customiser la couleur de vos
écouteurs par rapport à votre tenue du
jour vous pouvez le faire alors là je
suis sur un espèce de petit bleu mais si
je veux mettre de l'oranger je peux le
mettre en orange et si je me mets un
bavère et un rose fuchsia ça serait
bizarre mais je peux le faire donc je
peux vraiment complètement le
personnaliser et c'est là où c'est cool
c'est qu'en fait ces petits écouteurs
ils deviennent des accessoires de mode
et ça c'est chouette alors regardez
parce que je peux aussi choisir
manuellement je vais dans ma palette de
couleurs et là je viens le choisir étage
par étage vous voyez j'ai différentes
niveaux donc je vais choisir par exemple
étage du Centre je vais me mettre un
petit bleu je vais me dire je vais me
mettre celui-là je vais me mettre
ensuite à côté un petit rouge à côté un
orange et à côté un jaune je suis un
grand Gaudin ici je vais mettre j'en
sais rien moi je vais mettre du bon bout
et juste là je vais mettre un mystère je
fais appliquer et voyez ça arrive comme
par magie je vais les retrouver ici vous
avez compris l'idée on vient totalement
personnaliser mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque vous venez ensuite dans lumière
là vous choisissez comment va se
comporter la lumière vous avez à l'aine
Allen en fait ça va venir moduler voyez
ça disparaît ça revient doucement
essayer ça vous avez les impulsions
alors les impulsions c'est assez marrant
aussi ça le fait partir du bas et ça le
fait monter vers le haut en fait vous le
voyez dans l'application la vraie ça
illustre très très bien la pulsion c'est
ça vous avez l'ondulation qui part du
centre et qui va moduler vers le haut et
vers le bas en même temps et ça sur le
rythme de la musique et puis là vous
avez le niveau de luminosité plus vous
le baissez moins vous en aurez plus vous
le montez plus vous en aurez puis
brillant il reste fixe comme vous le
souhaitez donc ça c'est marrant et je
vais vous montrer parce qu'on va se
mettre un peu de musique mais c'est la
lumière pour que ça ressemble bien alors
on va se mettre un petit Rammstein parce
qu'on a envie que ça envoie un peu de
bois on se met un petit doigt et on se
fait plaisir on y va vous voyez c'est
marrant parce que c'est en train de
moduler en fait par rapport à la musique
j'ai baissé encore un peu la lumière et
quand je vais passer sur le refrain ça
va tartiner un max donc le truc est très
cool en fait si vous voulez parce que on
peut totalement venir personnaliser
l'histoire et comme on est dans une
application on peut dire moduler
différentes choses regardez je vous
montre vous venez dans écouter juste ici
vous pouvez venir moduler par exemple
votre équaliseur équilibré voire plus de
base plus d'aigu alors bon je vous le
dis c'est LE FUR et équilibré ici vous
êtes des drivers de 11 mm qui fonctionne
bien mais ce qu'on va mettre en avant
ici surtout c'est l'expérience visuelle
plus que l'expérience audio ça
fonctionne on est quand même sur des
écouteurs à 139 dollars on peut pas tout
leur demander d'autant plus qu'elles ont
en plus de ça et vous le voyez en
dessous une réduction de bruit réduction
de bruit active c'est à dire que pour
ceux qui sont pas les micros l'extérieur
vont venir capter le son et par un
système de HORSE ils vont venir annuler
le bruit extérieur je vous cache pas que
c'est pas la meilleure réduction de
bruit que j'ai entendu ça existe c'est
la mais c'est pas foufou vous avez soit
la suppression de bruit soit le mode
transparence qui va venir rajouter un
petit peu le son provenant de
l'extérieur dans vos écouteurs pour
entendre vraiment ce qui se passe soit
vous le désactivez personnellement je
conseille ici de le désactiver je trouve
que ça n'apporte pas globalement grand
chose de même que l'équaliseur vous le
laissez sur équilibrer ça suffirait
largement autre fonctionnalité dans
l'application parce que vous avez quand
même pas mal de choses vous venez ici et
vous allez avoir un contrôle du toucher
alors ça ça c'est marrant pourquoi parce
qu'en fait au niveau de vos écouteurs
normalement sur les pavés tactiles c'est
vraiment sur l'extérieur et eux comme
sur l'extérieur ils ont cette partie là
et bien les pattes tactile en fait ce
qui va être tactile c'est la petite
partie là qui va être tactile et que
vous allez trouver en venant poser vos
doigts et cliquez dessus vous voyez vous
appuyez là et là je l'ai donc deux fois
play ça me revient Rammstein deux fois
pause voilà très simplement et ça vous
venez le programmer directement dans
l'application regardez-vous laver juste
ici contrôleur gauche tapez deux fois
marche arrêt vous pouvez venir choisir
chanson suivante chanson précédente
suppression de bruit interruption de la
lumière aucune action donc vous avez le
choix en fait vous êtes personnalisé
alors pour des fois il vous propose à
gauche deux fois play deux fois pose
c'est pareil à droite exactement la même
chose trois fois à gauche morceau
suivant vous maintenez et vous appuyez
vous venez couper la lumière à droite
vous tapez 2 fois play pause vous
appuyez trois fois morceau suivant et là
vous voyez par exemple si je peux me
dire chanson précédente ce serait
beaucoup plus logique de faire ça
précédente suivante on appuie trois fois
et puis ensuite je peux venir activer ou
supprimer la suppression de bruit ici en
maintenant appuyer mon doigt ok vous
pouvez venir activer aussi la détection
intra-auriculaire donc lorsque vous
mettez vos écouteurs en gros lorsque
vous les enlever la musique s'arrête
trouver megipods donc vous allez venir
envoyer de la musique directement pour
venir les voir et pour même en plus
mettre de la lumière ça l'effet
clignoter si c'est dans le noir par
exemple ça peut être très pratique si
vous voulez pas réveiller quelqu'un avec
les écouteurs seront de ses eaux claque
on fait ça il y a de la lumière bon mise
à jour du firmware aussi couleur
personnalisé dans les appels
téléphoniques donc vous recevez un coup
de fil moi je l'ai mis en bleu pour le
mettre en rouge en rose comme vous
voulez ça c'est à vous de voir et puis
vous avez une boutique ici et ça donc le
truc est très très marrant donc
l'application je la trouve quand même
plutôt bien faite elle va vraiment dans
l'idée de ses écouteurs où on vient tout
personnaliser et vraiment à côté
extérieur qui est super joli donc je
trouve ça très cool mais venir acheter
des petites coquilles en plus là vous
retrouvez directement et vous pouvez
même voir ce que ça donnerait par
exemple celui-là j'appuie dessus vous
voyez je vois ma coquille à quoi elle
ressemble à j'en ai plein d'autres vous
avez le rendu également par rapport à ce
que vous vous avez paramétré donc ça
permet réellement de voir ce qu'il en
est et même en couleur avec un petit
effet derrière donc l'idée de venir
personnaliser d'avoir des écouteurs que
personne n'aura jamais je vous laisse
regarder le défilement il y en a
énormément de coquilles donc globalement
vous avez de quoi faire vous voyez le
tarif de la coquille individuellement
pour remettre par dessus c'est 19
dollars 99 oui ici on se parle bien de
tarif en dollars je vais vous montrer
celle-là il y a un côté un peu zébré ok
why not pour libérer le sauvage ou la
sauvage qui est en vous ça sent les
facilement mais je pense que quand vous
les avez vos oreilles ça se barre pas
donc là ça va c'est plutôt cool vous
avez également leur slogan d'air Shine
donc vous venez le poser comme vous
voulez directement sur votre jpods comme
ça on peut venir lire le message
directement sur vos oreilles et
m'envoyer aussi un autre zébré un peu
plus large donc si vous aimez bien les
Zèbres voyez vous avez différentes
finitions comme ça il y en a pour tout
un chacun de la tête de mort du zèbre et
compagnie je trouve ça assez marrant
donc ça ce sont les coquilles qu'on peut
bien prendre en plus et qui vous permet
de customiser toujours plus vos jpoz et
n'oubliez pas que les écouteurs sont à
139 dollars et d'ailleurs si c'est
produit vous intéresse je vous mets le
lien juste en bas dans la description
alors quelques infos techniques parce
qu'ici on est une chaîne qui parle de
TEC je vous l'ai dit ça des drivers
c'est du 11 mm on a une réduction de
bruit qui va jusqu'à 25 décibels bon je
vous l'ai dit ok ça anecdotique si vous
le souhaitez vous pouvez le mettre
personnellement je vous recommande pas
le nécessairement de venir le mettre au
niveau de l'autonomie et c'est ça qui
est assez marrant vous avez en fait une
autonomie qui va jusqu'à 5 heures par
écouteur 5h ça va être la réduction de
bruit coupé donc c'est ce que je viens
vous recommander ici si vous activez la
réduction bruit vous descendez à et si
vous activez la réduction de bruit et
que bien évidemment et bien vous mettez
les lumières ce qui est le but ici vous
descendez à 3h par contre en 10 minutes
de charge vous avez récupéré deux heures
d'écoute donc ça surcharge très
rapidement une recherche complète se
fait en une heure 50 et vous montez
grâce à l'étui jusqu'à 20h d'Auton 20
heures d'autonomie réduction de bruit
coupé et sans lumière des écouteurs
pouvaient sortir à tout temps vous avez
une certification
IPX4 résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
alors on se parle pas ici tempête soyons
clairs sont pas très lourds ils sont
confortables 5,4 g mal confort je trouve
très très cool ils viennent se
positionner très facilement ça me va
bien les connexes c'est du a.c usbc on
est sur la base de la base ici du
Bluetooth 5.2 plus de 300000
combinaisons de lumière autant
dire que je sois
tous applications grâce à de l'aide RGB
je trouve le principe extrêmement malin
une fois de plus un produit que j'avais
vu nulle part si on les veut c'est pour
montrer c'est pour que ça se voit
l'extérieur qu'on voit la musique parce
que globalement lorsque vous baladez
dans la rue ils a pas à vous mettre
devant un miroir ou de vous regarder
avec votre téléphone toute la journée on
va pas le voir c'est vraiment pour venir
partager montrer les rythmes montrer la
musique partager l'ambiance et savoir
comme un accessoire de mode ça qui est
vachement intéressant et ça va pas
forcément être fait pour tout le monde
mais tous ceux et toutes celles qui
souhaitent avoir un accessoire de mode
aux oreilles qui veulent pouvoir changer
la lumière en fonction de l'ambiance du
moment en fonction de la tenue du moment
vous pouvez le faire très facilement
donc je trouve ça extrêmement malin je
trouve ça très très cool donc je vous
invite à me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez s'il vous intéresse une fois de
plus je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description merci à JPS d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo et j'espère que
vous vous allez bien que vous portez
bien diplôme d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires et on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler tech bien
évidemment et de plein d'autres choses
ça c'est cool je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]